Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn. It's
the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
April 21st,
2014 being recorded live on
digital tape and the good all you
in my fucking bedroom. Oh Man. It's
great to be back. Well, let me tell Ya.
Well I'll tell ya and a crazy flight
color back. Yeah, no, I am. Uh,
I'm excited to be back. I'm happy to
be back. Uh, I didn't want to leave,
but you know, some point you got
to grow up, right? Go back to work.
You know, put some food,
no fucking brown sack.
Getting to some fucking car that has a
hatchback inch your way into traffic.
Can I go? Can I go? Thank you.
Thank you. One person who cares,
you know,
to put on Jack FM and sit there and cry
as they call songs that you thought came
out two weeks ago. Classics. Good.
It's been a long time.
That's a 40th anniversary.
Some metal heads going to co mutually the
cube and the TV would go fuck yourself.
All right, take off. You have rob Helford,
leather studded gloves and go clean up
the garbage to scope disposal. Right.
What did I say?
Garbage disposal.
Cause that's what I think of
when I think of those gloves.
The ones that go all the way
up to your elbows, you know,
basically the glove form
of superhero boots. Um,
anyway, so this is the Monday morning
podcast. If you're new to the podcast,
welcome.
Thank you for listening.
I know you have your choice between mine
and nine zillion other fucking podcasts.
I mean at this point, I mean, you
guys could all have a podcast,
but why would you do that?
Why would you do that when you could
just sit down and listen to someone else
attempt to do it? I don't
fucking know. Um, yes.
So back in the United States and uh,
I had an unbelievable trip.
You know what fucking story I kept trying,
I kept forgetting to tell
you guys and a helmet on.
It's still boring you with
stories about France, but I,
I did have a fucking great time over
there. Um, which is an understatement.
Anyways,
I know like two weeks ago I told you,
or last week I told you the story
going to Omaha beach and the uh,
the American soldiers cemetery over
there and all that type of stuff. And um,
one of my podcast listeners sent me an
email a couple of months ago talking
about how after he took
the tour the next morning,
he woke up early and went down to Omaha
beach when there was nobody there,
you know, maybe one guy with
a dog and a Frisbee. Right?
And he just sat there on the, uh, on
the, on the beach and smoked a cigar.
And I was like, I got to fucking do
that. Right? I gotta fucking do that.
So I got my cigar,
I take the tour and I got that big stupid
Mercedes nine passenger bus that they
rented me. Cause I wanted a car
one way. And as I've told you guys,
time and time again on this podcast,
when you rent a car one way,
you are getting the fucking ugly duckling,
the one that they can't rent out.
You get in the Griswold family truckster
and that's what they gave me for two
fucking people, nine passenger. Right?
So I wake up the next morning
early nehes still sleeping and um,
you know,
my phone is dead and I'm not going to
take her phone because I don't to be here.
Why did you take my phone?
I was looking for it. I didn't
want to deal with that. Right?
So what I have is I have this gps
that was the shit in about 2002.
Okay.
I'm in another country.
I don't speak the language.
It's about eight o'clock in the morning.
And I go out and I get it in this
fucking nine passenger bus by myself.
And I start driving and I already
can't get it to say Omaha beach.
I can't read half the signs. And I'm
just laughing as I'm driving away going,
I'm going to get lost.
And I keep turning around every
time I make a left to turn around.
And rather than looking at a sign,
I'm trying to look at something that
stands out, a billboard or something.
And I'm trying to remember like,
remember that fucking game, Simon, right.
The little colors and it would go
all around is a fucking great game.
Great electronic game.
One of the few that I was allowed to have,
my parents never gave his video games,
never let us do any of that shit cause
they thought it was going to affect our
studies. You know, my dad's
like, you're not watching that
shit. Everybody. But yeah,
I want to play asteroids fucking books.
You know,
it's funny as I still flunked
everything in high school,
so maybe should've let me
play miss [inaudible] man.
Um, I didn't flunk it, but
I was in the, you know, if,
if my high school class was a
batting lineup, I was baton eighth,
right. Right before the
catcher. Um, anyways,
so,
uh,
so I get in this van and
I'm fucking laughing and I'm
trying to feel my way back
to where the tour guy drove us.
And you know,
every fucking 20 seconds is a goddamn
rotary round and round and round.
You go and you spit out the van and
I have no fucking idea where I'm at.
So I'm just laughing. I'm like, I don't
give a fuck. I know where the beach,
I know the beaches in this direction.
I'm just going in this direction.
And then I know I go left, go, shh.
As the French people say I'm going left
and then I'm just going to drive until I
see it and I'm going to get there.
And when smoke my cigar,
I'm going to complete this fucking
mission, right. And A and in way.
And I'll deal with the fact that I don't
know how to get back and that I have a
flight to catch, you know,
early afternoon. So, uh,
actually it wasn't even
eight in the morning.
He was like nine by the
time I got up or whatever.
So I kind of blew the
early morning part of it,
but I still wanted to go smoke the cigar.
So I'm driving and this
fucking thing is just taken me,
you know, I can't figure out how to input
it. I can't, there's no enter button.
I can't.
I'm going Omaha beach and I'm yelling at
the fucking thing and I'm screaming at
the about the rental car people.
How can you rent this fucking piece of
shit out and charge somebody fucking 20
francs a day for this God damn thing
or euros, whatever the fuck they on.
And I'm driving down the road and I
got the radio on because I'm trying to
immerse myself in the language.
That's what you supposed to do
when you learn a new language,
you just immerse yourself in it. Although
I'm sitting there speaking English,
which I shouldn't be doing,
I should be going mayor zoot or whatever
the fuck I was supposed to be yelling.
Um, but I wasn't, I was, I was speaking
in English. So anyways, I had on,
this is the point of the story I had
on French talk radio and it was fucking
hilarious. First of all to
speak at 90 miles an hour.
And I'm, I'm just, by the way,
they're talking, you can tell basically,
I don't know what they're talking about,
but you can kind of figure out like
what's going on. And somebody was like,
you know,
is we'll have a zip.
And then some other guy goes like
[inaudible] and the other guys like
[inaudible]. So it says the guy said
something and the other guy goes,
you know what the fuck's in? And the other
guy goes, no, no, no. I'm not saying,
I'm not saying it's a bad thing, I'm
just, you know, I'm just saying, oh Cleo,
what's up buddy? You haven't
been on the podcast in a while.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Get off the bed. Get off to
bed. Get off to bed. Sorry.
Can a fucking hit stop on the
record button. So anyways,
these guys are going back to Egypt.
The most helpful. You're getting money.
No then no, Eh, eh. So anyways,
I'm listening to this shit
and now I'm driving into fog.
I'm completely fucking lost and
I'm listening to these guys.
And what's funny over there is when
people talk and they're searching for a
word, they don't go, ah, cause
that's actually a word like Isla.
So you'd be like, have, so you be
going have, you wouldn't do that.
So what they do, they say is this is, this
is my, I think this is what's going on.
So rather than going I
or, um, they go, Ooh,
like e the EU are almost,
Ooh.
And so they kept doing that going,
Ooh,
as I'm driving through the fucking
fog and I'm laughing, just go, Ooh,
imitating the Shit is, I'm trying to
find this beach. And then, you know,
like when you trying to make a
point in any language, you're like,
you know, this guy is, is, is,
is, or you know, these people,
what they traded do it, whatever
you say, like the fucking word,
like 15 times in a row. So that's what
they kept going. They kept going like
a [inaudible] do, do, do.
And I'm driving in the fog. Go, go on a
stupid fucking French people.
I was screaming about them and the
stupid thing and long story short,
this fucking,
this fucking a tare,
mapquest, whatever the fuck
you call it makes me go left.
I'm going down these farm roads.
All right.
And now it literally feels like it's
1944 and some Germans are going to come
around the corner with a motorcycle
and a sidecar. I'm driving by the, uh,
the hedge rows.
I'm getting to like dark
roads and I'm just laughing.
I have no fucking idea where I'm at.
It's foggy.
I'm on a road that's so fucking small,
like I literally have to pull this
bus over to let somebody else go by.
They give the wave over there, by
the way, and I'm just driving a
Ooh,
drive on my way through
this fucking thing.
And I finally make it to the road like
an hour later and my flight is leaving at
two and a half hours.
I have no fucking idea how to get back.
And I get to the place where I'm going
to make the left to drive up to the beach
and it says road closed,
you know,
and you gotta be sitting
there going, Bill, you know,
3000 people died that way that day.
I mean on that beach.
They saw their mission through,
they just kept common and common and
common until they fucking met their
objective.
Are you going to let one little French
police barricade that says erect or stop,
whatever the fuck it says you're going
to let that stop you or are you just
going to drive this nine passenger van
around it and use the fact that you don't
speak the language as a God damn.
Excuse it.
Ooh, do, do, do, do
right. I pussied out. I was just like,
I gotta go to the fucking airport.
I don't even know where I'm at.
And I fucking turned around like the
coward that cries in the foxhole.
So now I've drive it back into the fog
as you, but do you have it?
You have to a do a De, de, de,
de and all.
Uh,
those kinds sweats all teeth.
Drive it back into this fucking fog.
Okay.
And will you on Joey? Doo, Doo, Doo Doo.
And don't, it took me like fucking,
it took me like fucking two hours.
We almost missed our goddamn flight.
I'm driving around rotary after fucking
rotary and I can't find this place.
And then finally I came in bay. You,
they have like this old part of town,
you know, they got all the lead home
strip malls and shit. Not Strip malls,
but just like just regular shit
please to get 1 cent beach, um,
awesome. [inaudible] on jewelry.
They got all that bullshit,
right? But then in the center of town,
they have like the old school, like,
like the old part of town,
like old Montreal, Old Vegas,
whatever the fuck you want to call it.
So I see this church and I'm like,
I remember that fucking church.
My hotel is somewhere near that church
and there's a little brook near it.
So I drive back and it was
the most frustrating half
hour my life. Cause I knew
that I was near my fucking hotel, but
I just couldn't find the fucking thing.
And finally
I found the brook and what I had to do,
I had to just,
I just got out of the van and started
walking around and then I finally,
and I'm walking up to people and
I'm going, uh, uh, excuse me. Um,
why? Uh, I was doing that. I was going,
ah, so it's actually going to excuse him.
Why subsequent, excuse me, have, um,
or has whatever I'm saying.
I was like, excuse him,
why [inaudible] uh,
Winston Churchill Motel,
motel day, Winston Churchill,
because that wasn't even named my hotel,
but I,
my hotel was right next to
it and then it would be like,
uh, Jenna, they go, God
dammit, fuck. And I,
it took me like five people
walking up to him, um,
and I finally was able to find the brook
and then I found it and I saw them if
there's my fucking hotel.
And then I just took this,
I had to run back to the van and weave my
way around it. I'm freaking out, no one,
my wife's going to be pissed at me and
I finally get to the hotel and, uh,
we got enough time to get to the airport
and I fucking go in a hotel room and
she's still sleeping. She's still
sleeping. She's like, hey baby,
did you make it to the beach? And
I was like, no, I couldn't find it.
That stupid piece of shit.
Mapquest fucking thing from 1982 took me
down a country road and she just goes,
oh,
why didn't you just take my phone honey?
And that's the story.
Um, but anyways, I'm keeping up with my,
my French shit. Um, I'm going to try to,
uh, I dunno, I gave up on
the Spanish stuff. I just,
there's something about
the French language where I
flunked it for three years
in high school and it's familiar and I,
and I feel like maybe through learning
French I could somehow learn Spanish.
I don't know. A lot of you guys are
sitting there going, fuck you, Bill.
You're never going to learn this shit.
And you know what? I thrive off of that.
Go Fuck Yourself. I'm going to learn
how to speak it. And when I do,
I'm going to do an entire podcast
and French on for, I'll say,
all right, let's do some advertising
for this week. He voice everybody. Um,
want your business to make more
money. He voice can help. Here's how,
when your customers call,
you'll have your own toll free number,
professional greeting, dial by
name directory, and Mola. Uh,
you'll sound like a fortune 500
company and really stand out from the
competitors. Eve Voice lets you give out
your number that rings wherever you are.
You can be at your kid's soccer game,
you'll never miss a chance to grow your
business evolves even takes all your
voicemails,
transcribes them and sends them to
you instantly as a text or an email.
Couldn't be any more easier so you could
check voicemails before the meeting
ends so you don't look.
Route he voiced is only 13 bucks a month
and right now my listeners can try he
voice for absolutely free for 60 days,
60 days.
That's right. A 60 day free
trial. Don't put this off.
Turn down the radio, get
to a computer, I guess.
Mute this Patek podcast and set up your
ear voice 60 day free trial now so you
can see what I mean.
Go to [inaudible] Dot Com Promo Code Bill.
That's he voice.com promo right? Go Bill.
All right, the next one, legal zoom.
Everybody monitor technology is great.
Smartphones,
iPads and other gadgets make it
easy to do so many great things,
but why is it that our lives seem
to get busier at the same time?
Legal Zone, getting
philosophical here. Well,
when it comes to getting
the legal help you need,
legal zoom provides a great solution
that works with your busy schedule.
Let's face it,
the legal system is complicated.
There are better things you
could do with your time.
Thankfully legal zoom is there for you,
so if you're thinking
about starting a business,
forming an LLC or getting a
trademark will or living trust,
legal zoom gets the job done right,
you'll get a,
you'll get the personal attention you
need and they'll help you take care of all
the details.
Legal Zoom has been helping families and
small business owners for 14 years and
they received an a plus from
the better business bureau.
Call or visit legal zoom today for an
extra discount. You can enter burpee.
You are are in the referral
box at checkout. That's
legalzoom.com discount code,
burr legal zoom provides legal
help through independent attorneys,
through independent attorneys
and self help services.
But they are not a law firm. Go to legal
zoom.com. Enter Discount Code burpee.
You are, are, you are. Yeah.
That was pretty good reading for
this week. Um, oh by the way,
uh, I've been obsessed with, um,
with German cars ever since.
Um, I went on that day,
that Dee day trip, you know, and
I looked at one of our tanks,
you know, our tag basically if
a Chevy Chevette was a tank,
that's what the fuck we were
rolling out a, which once again is,
I'm really starting to understand why
Tom Brokaw called them the greatest
generation because, uh, I,
I couldn't even make it to Omaha beach
in a fucking Mercedes Benz nine passenger
with fucking satellite help you,
these tanks compared to what the
Germans had. It's unfucking believable.
So I actually, I, you guys got to see
this video that I watched this week.
If you're into, they basically show, um,
then putting together the engine that
they stick in one of their unbelievable
cars.
And this guy hand builds the entire thing.
What the help of some actually some really
cool robots and you know that I'm not
into robots,
but what I like about these robots is
they're doing the pain in the ass job that
you don't want to do.
Like you know when you squeeze that
fucking glue I guess to basically,
I don't know if you're
sealing the head to the block,
I thought there was a gasket there. I
have no idea. It was one of those deals.
I didn't one of those deals, but this
fucking robot thing just, it's got the,
the sealer and it fucking
goes right around the edge.
And then when he get to his screw
it goes like around the rotary,
like me in the bus and then just
fucking continues on and it's perfect.
Then you line up.
So basically the guy puts
the whole glorious engine
together and then in the end
he has his own seal with his name.
He puts his fucking name on
the engine and a, I was like,
oh my God,
I got to get a Mercedes someday.
And then I looked up how much they
cost and I was like, oh my God,
I got to rent a Mercedes someday.
I know he can get some
of the smaller ones,
but you know the one you fucking want,
you know,
you know the Mercedes you want,
you don't want to get those fucking,
the lower end ones. Fuck those ones. You
want the one that you're walking up to,
somebody opens the door for you and
you have a briefcase handcuffed to your
fucking wrist. That's the model you
want. Like the one I looked up, I'm like,
well fuck this. What's the best
one that got? So they're uh,
basically in the BMW's got the m's,
the m series,
the m five [inaudible] three and all
that with Mercedes, they have the AMG.
So I'm like, oh, let me check out
was a fucking four door sedan.
They weren't a $237,000 for
this fucking thing, you know?
And I was just like, all right,
well, you know, that was, that was,
that was a fun fantasy.
Maybe they'll go buy a used one from
somebody getting a goddamned divorce or
some shit. I don't know
what, but I definitely got
to, hopefully I'll remember.
Maybe I'll make a note right now.
I'll do that. Cause I always say,
and I'm going to put that video up.
Hey everybody,
I'm putting the video up and a,
I guess what it's going to be up
on the website and it never is.
If you guys just saw how I just
typed Mercedes with my right hand,
I'm lefthanded Mer ces mercies.
MERCI.
MERCI. Wait a minute. I put
the damn, I swear to God.
Am I do I am also dyslexia. M. E r.
C. E. D. E. S. That looks
right. Right? Mercedes video.
Stupid.
Why do you have to install your yourself?
Why can't you love yourself and just
tie a string around your finger?
Um, anyways. Yes.
So I am back in the United States of
America and uh, I'm getting back to a,
watching American sports and um,
Jesus Christ, my picks week,
I swear to God and the Nhl.
What a fucking train wreck that was.
That was like some Paul Versey Shit.
I went on there and I only picked one
upset. I really hope he hears that.
Can you guys please send
that link to him like Paul?
Like please send to this entire section
if he can't. Paul, you listen to this.
I went,
I did what you did.
I went with all the fucking favorites and
I'm going to give you my results right
now. If you're listening. New Jersey
Zone, dude, I called it Paul Versey.
Alright. Flyers verse the
Rangers. I picked the fucking,
that series is actually one one.
Boston,
Detroit. I picked a Bruins.
That series is one. One. Uh,
Montreal actually picked Montreal. Jesus
Christ. Where the fuck are all my losses?
Oh yeah, San Jose, Los
Angeles. I picked Los Angeles.
I guess they're not the favorites,
but I looked at San Jose fucking they
like when the president's trophy every
year. Then they fucking, they lose
usually in the first goddamn round.
I'm not shitting on the San Jose Sharks.
Come on Jack.
Mvp Sports. We got all the
jerseys. We got the shacks.
The seal is the charges in more.
Um, I'll never forget that.
Read every time I say San Jose Sharks,
I always think about MVP sports in Boston.
Um,
yeah, so I just, they just
stay. They do whatever year.
I'm stating a fact. Alright.
Pittsburgh. Columbus. I picked the, uh,
the penguins. That's one. One. Colorado,
Minnesota. Pick Minnesota that
download to Chicago. Saint Louis.
I picked the blues. I bet. I'm sorry
I picked Chicago. They're down o two.
I don't know. But anyways, it's been
a hell of a fucking, uh, actually my,
wait a minute, let's go
back here. Was I that bad?
Maybe I'm giving versus a compliment. All
right. Minnesota while they pick them,
they download two black
hawks. They down. Oh two.
I did pick the ducks.
I picked the king's deer down.
O Two. I picked J I think that
I'm doing all right. Look,
if the brewers win this series and the
fucking penguins win that series and the
flyers when then I, I think
I'm all right. And then,
you know what I would hope Paul
Versey and apology. Um, anyways,
how great is the playoffs, man? I swear
to God, if you're still watch an NBA hoop,
I understand it. It's a great
game to watch, but come on.
Why don't you watch a real fucking
leak instead of the NBA? Who's kidding?
Who if you really watched the NBA,
I mean that is the most
manipulated fucking sport.
Okay?
I mean, I know it's all, all of
them are a God damn business.
I would say the NFL is
the least manipulated.
And I know a lot of people
don't like the new rules,
but everybody's got to play by him.
But like I've said this a zillion times,
but everybody's got to fucking Seahawks.
Goddamn Seahawks.
Just want to fucking Superbowl.
Okay,
that's great.
One of the fuck of the Marin is going to
be in a position where they could spend
money to compete with the red sox and
the Yankees and they can give me a break
and ain't fucking happening.
Although they just blew a bunch
of money on Robinson Cano.
Okay.
Paul versus man crush.
MMM.
They had the fuck. They said
what a bunch of idiots they were.
Did they learn anything from the
Texas fucking ranges? You know,
blow 200 million on a shortstop
and you have no money for pitching.
So you didn't blow 200 oh what if
it's on the other side of second base?
What's a little fucking blow 200
million on this guy. So anyways,
the uh, yeah, the NBA is basically
a, I feel like the NBA is like,
it's like wrestling two years before they
admitted that it's just was all right,
you know,
were fake fighting but we're really
hurting each other and then everybody was
just like, all right cool. You
know, and we'll, we'll go with this.
That's what they should do in the NBA.
Just go look,
they're really playing the games.
But you know,
we got to make sure certain teams get
to a certain point in the playoffs so we
could get the ratings we need so we can
all make our money and we refused to pay
the referees anything more
than we're giving them,
despite the fact that an,
an NBA official has more power than any
other official in the four major sports.
Okay.
Now I just pause there cause I went for
all the fucking more on sports fans will
be like, yeah, you put the
bullshit. It's true. No other sport.
Can you just sit at fucking
guy down a star player.
You can sit them down in the first
quarter. Give them two quick ones.
Second quarter, give him that. I've
said this a zillion fucking time.
She can keep them on the bench.
The whole God damn game. Yeah.
You can't keep Tom Brady on the bench.
You,
you'd have to kick them out for something.
But what does Tom Brady going to do
that's gonna make you kick them out? Huh?
You could, what are you gonna penalize
him for his Dimbleby in too deep. Right?
Do you going to take out some
measuring things? Stick like woods.
Somebody has like a two curve to stick
in hockey. You're not throwing them out
anyways. I'm not saying you
can't manipulate the game,
but nowhere can you manipulate
it more than the fucking NBA.
So I'm just saying come on over
and watch the fucking hockey. It's,
it's been unbelievable so
far. And, uh, the Bruins,
uh, Detroit series is, is, is
shaping up to go seven games.
It's been fucking great. Uh, the game one.
MMM.
I mean, they just made us look old
and slow. Detroit is so God damn fast.
And let me ask you this.
When was the last time you saw Detroit
Redwings team where every pass wasn't
tape to tape. Like what, 1994. I mean,
they going on like fucking 17 years.
The puck movement on that
team is fucking unbelievable.
And that souk is from another planet.
That goal that he scored to win game one.
It was so fucking good.
I couldn't even get mad. I mean, it
definitely took the wind out of my sails,
but I was just like, Jesus Christ, that
was the thing of fucking beauty. Um,
that backhand pass he had in game two.
He's fucking incredible. And uh, so what,
anyways, they basically, for those of
you who weren't watching, they, um,
they were just flying all around the
ice and we look like we were like a
division two hockey team
trying to keep up with them.
So you knew what was going to
happen. All right. Game Two,
we're going to get physical and
that's what we were able to do.
So now game three, uh, is coming
up. Now they're going to adjust.
Yeah.
You know, to us getting
physical with them, you know,
it's always hard after you
won a fucking game too. Um,
you know, to win that next game
in the playoffs because you know,
you won the game, so you're like, yeah,
I guess we keep doing what we're doing.
You basically have to wait to
see the other teams adjustments.
That's why I love playoff series and uh,
and that type of stuff.
So I know there's a bunch of Detroit
Redwings fangs and haters or the Bruins
fans.
Right now you probably have your face
like a centimeter away from your Jesus
Christ.
How long was that in Europe?
Like an inch away from your fucking
a millimeter away from your, uh,
your recording device right now going,
is he going to bring up Milan,
Lou Cheech in his piece of
shit? Yes. Move. Absolutely.
Somebody said go. I would love to
hear you. Dyfed Milan blue cheese.
He basically speared this guy.
MMM.
Like I think he got half taint, half
ball bag, hopefully the guys balls,
hopefully Milan stick.
He basically,
he hit the sweet spot of the ball bag
that causes both of your fucking balls to
go sideways.
Like those side impact airbags
just fucking to the side.
And then his stick came down
before they clang back together,
which still would definitely hurt.
But when are they going
to clang back together?
You'd rather be bald the ball rather than
both balls hitting the fucking wood or
the whatever the fuck
his sticks made out of.
Now that's the second time he's done
that in three fucking weeks and I can't
defend it.
I think he should've got suspended.
I think it's a fucking joke
that that was a $5,000 fine.
$5,000 fine.
So basically what you're telling me
NHL is you're telling me that Danny
Dekeyser, Kaiser's balls are
worth no more than 2,500 each.
Is that what you're telling me?
I'm your for your basically fucking with
the man's ability to start a family.
This goes beyond the game.
A hockey
that,
look, you know what it is,
is it's, it's a new move.
I haven't seen anybody
do that consistently.
I've seen somebody while somebody
is looking at him, you know,
and it's the shaft of the, and they'll
kind of fucking bring it up like that. Oh,
he acted it out. You like
that? No, fucking bring it up.
But to have a guy skating
up the fucking ice,
not even looking at you and you come
there and you turn your stick in the blade
up.
Okay.
And give the guy a fucking would up a
cut to his Tate and ball area. I mean,
Jesus Christ. I'll tell you that. That's,
that's some new forensic shit right there.
You know, actually you don't use that.
That's actually the only person who knows
what that bruises looks like is a Gyn
forensics. Actually, I got, I got, I
got a Bruce Ball bag and taint one time.
I don't know if I ever
told you guys this story.
I was working in a warehouse and a,
we had a softball team.
I was basically an excuse for
people to drink fucking, uh,
cause lite and wine coolers.
It was the 80s,
the lady's tea did drink the wine coolers
and then when I played in the league,
it was right before, you know,
wine coolers suggest come out.
So there was actually a few guys
having some out of a four pack.
Uh,
and it was,
it was that maybe that three week
window before it closed where you're,
your entire manhood was judged if
you ever had a fucking wine cooler.
But there was, when they
first came out, you know,
Bartles and Jaymes these two fucking cute
old guys doing these silly commercials
that it was actually, oh, let me try
this. You know, they, that was the,
that that was like the Zima
version of wine. So anyways,
anyways, so whatever, I'm on base,
I'm trying to go first to third
on some fucking single, the right.
And My boss is on third base and the ball
comes in. Oh, came in from left field.
So I must've been on second base.
I never had any wheels,
so there's no fucking way.
I was trying to go first to
third on something that's left.
So I'm running into second and I come
in standing up and they threw the ball
was,
maybe it was the centerfield cause they
throw it to the outside a third base.
So he's basically,
he's reaching over on the,
into foul territory and
he back handed backhand.
How did he do it?
Yay.
He backhanded it and then
swooped up to try to tag me.
And I came in standing up and he fucking
with the ball in the web of his glove,
went fucking full lop to
my fucking under carriage.
And I remember standing on third
base waiting for the paint,
you know,
like it didn't happen at first.
And then immediately I'm thinking of that
Eddie Murphy bit that he did on one of
his specials where when you
get hit in the balls so bad,
there's that delay and then
the, uh, then, then, then yeah,
that's usually a medium hit. If you get
hit in the balls really bad, you just go,
oh,
and you go down.
But if there's that there's that light
to medium hit where you get hit and it,
there's a delay in the penalty, the
penalty, the, the, the pain. Um,
I dunno, Eddie Murphy did a fucking
phenomenal bid on it. So anyways,
and it never came.
And I'm standing there and I'm sitting
there waiting for people to start giving
me shit to be like,
dude,
you just got hit in the balls and you
didn't feel any pain. How small are they?
Right.
And it wasn't until like fucking
like two, three days later,
I'm in the shower, right?
And I'm cleaning myself and
all of a sudden I just fucking,
I don't know how I, they all had a
fuck. Do you look at your tank? I Dunno.
I was washing my ball bag and I
saw a little bit of Cola, right.
Look down and I swear to God,
the back half of my sac right to
the tape was like popsicle purple.
All right. And I didn't even feel
that. So I can't even imagine
what fucking poor daddy to cars,
his ball bag and fucking taint look
when he took a piece of lumber.
I mean, it's just completely, and I'm
gonna say this, Milan, Lou Cheech,
he had up until this point,
other than just the haters that don't
like it because he's a classic power
forward that can score goals and beat the
fuck out of anybody on your team if he
chooses.
Right.
And I don't want to hear
any of you guys going like,
go blue picto he booked on the fucking,
who the fuck was the goad the
Canadians had back in the day?
He was actually one of the, uh, uh,
I shouldn't say gone. He was the one,
he made it an art form. Charles,
uh, George de la rock. He's like,
why does he fight that guy?
And it's just like, well, okay,
we're trying to win a
hockey game here is stupid.
So we're supposed to have a fucking
all star square off with the goat.
Okay.
Keep calling him a goon square off
with the goddamn artist of fighting,
fighting a martial artists on skates.
He supposed to fight this guy.
All right? I'm not saying he would have
won, but he couldn't hold, held his zone.
He's a fucking big guy,
but he's risking injury and he's going
to be sitting in the penalty box.
We don't have him for five fucking
minutes. And you don't have George.
Laura could stupid. It's fucking stupid.
That's like people yesterday was gay.
Well,
it gave me shit on Twitter asking why
Chara didn't fight that guy that he was a
foot taller than that guy was trying
to go to him into dropping the gloves.
So he sits in the penalty box and anybody
who fucking says the chart was a pussy
because he didn't fight that guy.
You're a fucking moron and
you don't understand the game.
I don't have any care how many
fucking games you watched.
So Danal Chara arguably still the
best defenseman in the league.
If not,
he's top two or three.
Okay,
so he's going to drop the
gloves with the forward
and then it go sit down
and maybe get an extra two.
We're an entirely different team.
When that guy's in the box, you're,
you're a fucking moron. You saw him
laughing at the guy going, all right,
you drop him first. Even then,
that would have been stupid.
So anyways,
loot Cheech,
he only had one bad incident as far as,
now granted I'm also prejudice cause I'm
a Bruins fan was when he fucking took a
run at a Ryan Miller. A hope. I'm
getting these names right dude.
I'm still a little jet. Like that
didn't sound right when I said it.
Reggie Miller, Ryan Miller. Um,
okay.
So he had that one.
Everybody has their one,
I got pissed and I got
far state of Blah Blah.
But now he's got that and he's got
two Spearings of the under carriage.
So I think from Milan to get his rep back,
he's going to have to be like
lady big for the next seven years.
But I think that those two,
are they going to haunt them for awhile?
You can't fucking do that.
You can't do that.
And that's a God damn shame that the
Nhl said that poor Danny dekeyser is
fucking balls and only worth $2,500 each.
I mean they come on
though.
Those guys at pawn shop would have
given you more fucking money for those.
And those guys don't pay shit.
Hey,
can I get 2,500 for the my balls? And
then that bald headed guy, it'd be like,
he'd be like, and how much you
really want? 2,500 each year,
cunt.
I hate that everybody a pussy on the,
on that fucking show
when he comes walking in,
you come in with that whatever you got.
And he's like, Oh yeah, that looks great.
What do you want for it? It
would, no matter what you say,
can I get 1 cent for this? He is. How much
do you really want? He's fucking joke.
That's what I want. Fuck off.
Now it's 2 cents. Um, anyways,
that's why I stopped watching that show.
There's something about the way that
they do that that I don't enjoy it yet.
I can watch fast and loud and I think
it's absolutely fucking hilarious watching
Richard Rawlings bus, those people
down. There's just something,
I don't know the way he does it.
It's so God damn funny if you guys
watch any of the new episodes.
Okay.
Where he went up and he met some
guy named so and so, six pack Magoo,
whatever his fucking name
in the middle of Minnesota
and the guys shit faced and he gives
Richard's buddy literally Ajara moonshine
that that guy starts drinking.
I forget what the fuck they went.
What were they trying to buy?
Oh,
a 57 Chevy. Is that what it was? Was
that the one with the dent in it?
I think he got it from that guy.
So he's trying to bust the guy down
to like 1500 bucks for this and it is,
it is a hunk of shit. But he, but it's
a 57 Chevy so he knows that, you know,
he can flip this thing and this guy's
hammered and he wants 1800 bucks and
Richard won't go above 1500 so the guy
breaks out some days and they rolled the
dice on the hood of the car and he
right there. I mean it's just, come on,
let's fucking America right there by way
he lost and he had to pay an 1800 bucks,
but still we got a 57 1800
bucks. It was a good, I'm, I'm,
I'm totally on a tangent
here. Um, so anyways,
so there you go to Detroit,
red wings fans and everybody else and
I want you to remember this. All right?
You myopic cunts. When somebody on
your team does something filthy,
don't be that Douche in
the sports bar who just,
who just blindly defend your fucking team.
If you have somebody on your
team does a piece of shit move,
you've got to call him. He got to call
it out and say it's a piece of shit move.
And that was an unbelievable
fucking piece of shit move.
He should've got suspended
and, and like, come on,
my balls are worth more than 2,500
bucks each. And I'm not, I'm not,
I'm not in the playoffs. I'm not even
in the league. I played pickup hockey.
Okay. And if you fucking hit me in
the nuts hard enough. All right.
When I go to sue you,
I'm not suing you for five grand.
All right, so there we go. There we go.
We are well into the podcast here.
The poor like yest uh
oh hey Billy red face.
It's got to do some standup comedy here
cause I have not done any standup comedy
since a uh, I did the uh, the all ins.
I hosted the all end tore down it
and um,
so I'm going to shake the rust off.
I've got a bunch of Shit I want to talk
about cause I'm doing some gigs this
week in Portland, Oregon and
Oregon. Portland, Maine, sorry,
Montpelier, Vermont in Albany, New York.
I believe that those are the
three gigs I'm doing this weekend.
I could probably go to my
podcast and my website,
maybe get that information for you.
I could probably do something
like that and be organized.
But that then again then if I did that,
it would not be the Monday
morning podcasts now would it? Um,
speaking of, uh, podcast, uh,
the wonderful all things comedy.
Okay.
A podcast network that me, Al Madrigal
and some friends of ours have started.
Uh, we actually, we got some new
people that are coming aboard. Doug,
Stan hope's going to be coming aboard.
Uh,
we got the A and we got, um,
Dean Edwards hosting the,
the father McKidd the
father muck and protocol.
How do you not listen to that podcast?
The father McCade protocol where he talks
about the do's and don'ts and what's
been done. All right. If he dean
Edwards name sounds familiar,
that's because you've seen him on a Colin
Ferguson SNL cast member or now an MTV
two's hit the guy code.
I also does spot on impressions.
He does Eddie Murphy, Bernie
Mac, Don Cheadle, Chris Rock.
He does a good impression of me. Check
it out at the AUC things comedy network,
the [inaudible] protocol.
Um,
actually I don't know if I was supposed
to announce Doug Stan hope yet.
I'll probably just fucked that up. But
there's rumors that he's coming a board.
How about that? Huh?
Little teaser. All right,
let's read a little more advertising
then we'll get into the, uh,
the question for this week.
I'll also check out all things,
comedy, Tom Cigars, new,
a special, completely normal.
It's fucking hilarious. And on,
and for those of you live out in
La, the next, um, all things comedy,
a comedy show out here,
the thing that we do every month,
so we can pay for our studios is going
to be at the bootleg theater and a yours
truly. We'll be on it along
with Neil Brennan and a host
of other raw all things,
comedy people. And uh, we're bringing
the lumber that night. So come on down.
I think the tickets are like 15 bucks.
Help us pay for the studio so we can keep
and will make you laugh. There you go.
All right. stamps.com everybody, when
you think about the, Oh, and by the way,
that shows April 29th.
Oh my dog's dreaming. Listen, my
dog's dreaming. Do you hit it?
Oh, now she's not going to
do it. She just went, whoa.
I wonder what they fucking
have nightmares about.
I think they're just like us.
Like they just know what they
know and they just fucking,
yeah,
I just have nightmares.
I fucking thing sleeps all God damn day.
My dog's been jet leg since I got it.
Um,
yeah.
All right.
stamps.com everybody,
when you think about the best
time to go to the post office,
she probably guessing before work,
after work or during lunch, wrong.
That's when it's the most crowded.
Everyone's going to be there at that time.
The truth is there is no convenient time
to go to the post office and that's why
you need stamps.com stamps.com with
stamps.com access all the services of the
post office right from your desk.
Buy and print official US postage for any
letter or package using your computer,
a printer. Uh, they just hand it and
then just hand it to your mail carrier.
So easy.
Oh your postman.
Oh that's why they didn't say it cause
I didn't want to be sexist or postwoman
your mail carrier and
unlike the post office,
stamps.com is open 24 seven with no
lines so you can get your mailing and
shipping done whenever you want,
whenever it's convenient for you.
I use stamps.com to send out
all my t shirts, all my posters,
all my DVDs that for some reason I'm
still trying to sell up to shows I'm,
and if I can use it, anybody can cause
I'm a moron right now. Use My last name,
birth for this special offer.
No risk trial plus $110 bonus offer that
includes a digital scale and up to $55
free postage. Don't wait. Go to
stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone at the top
of the homepage and type in burpee.
You are our that stamps.com and to burr.
Okay.
All right. And lastly, but not
leastly dollar shave club. Everyone,
nothing feels better than the, that first
shave with a fresh blade, right? Well,
something's do, but they involve
lubricant. Other than that,
it's smooth. It's close and the blade
is sharp as it's ever going to be.
It feels fantastic. Uh, but thanks
to the big shaves companies,
ridiculous prices. You can't afford
to use a fresh blade every week.
Uh, listen, I want to get involved in
your money, but a lot of you can't.
So you drag that Dell as blade across
your face for two, three, 10 weeks.
Who knows? Depends on how broke you
are. Why do you do that to yourself?
Jesus Christ. Bill, is there a solution?
Maybe because the only thing more
painful than shaving with an old blade is
shelling out 30 bucks for a pack of new
ones. It's a complete rip off. Well,
if you want to enjoy a fresh blade,
a fresh pack of blades every week,
but you know what? I'm take out a
second mortgage on your house there.
You got to join dollar shave club.com
for just a couple bucks a month.
Dollar Shave club.com ships the highest
quality blades you can get right to your
goddamn door. All right, seriously,
only six bucks for the best
quality blades you can get.
So every week yours truly,
I can pop in a fresh blade
and treat myself to an amazing
shave. It's incredible.
It's long overdue.
Thank God for Dollar Shave club.com you
get amazing quality blades in the mail
for a couple of bucks and you treat
yourself to a brand new blade every,
every single week. Aren't you worth
that? Isn't your face worth that?
That guy's balls are only worth 2,500
a whack. Can't you treat your face too?
A little bit of luxury.
Hundreds of thousands of guys have
upgraded their shaving with dollar shave
club.com and you know what?
I'm one of them and I'm loving it now.
What's your term? Shave time. Shave
money. Dollar Shave club.com/burr.
That's dollar shave club.com/burr.
Okay.
All right, let's get into the uh, some of
the emails here for this week. All right.
Caught cheating. Hey, they
have freckles, the clown.
I'm a married guy in my mid thirties.
I don't want to bore everyone with the
details, but I recently got cheated,
got caught cheating on my
wife with a 25 year old lady.
The affair went on for about four months.
And the truth is I really started to
like this girl after getting caught and
spending a few nights in a hotel,
my wife graciously suggest that we work
up with that we work on our marriage and
try to put this mess behind us.
We have two small church children,
so all logic points to me agreeing to
get the help we need and to move on with
our marriage.
The only problem is that I can't
get this other girl out of my mind.
These women are two polar opposites
of each other. My wife, uh,
a professional,
more conservative woman and the other
girl is a 25 year old party girl.
I know what the clear answer is,
but I do.
I snap out of this and put this
other girl out of my mind. All right?
This is a very simple
one, sir. First of all,
your wife is a saint.
All right?
That she's going to take you back and I'm
not judging you all right? I am a man.
We've all been there,
all right?
She's a sate that she's
gonna fucking take you back.
All right, so you got to treat it like
that one. And secondly, what do you do?
How do you get this girl out of your
mind? Easy. You wake up in the morning,
you walk into a bathroom, you close
the door and you'll rub one out tour,
and then you get on with your fucking day.
All
go in there, close the door, rub one out.
When you'd done rubbing one out,
it's just going to hit you.
What am I out of my fucking mind. Let's
to you describe, you know these women,
they're two polar opposites.
My wife is a professional,
more conservative woman and the
other is a 25 year old party girl.
Why don't you just say it?
Your wife is a kind of girl you marry
and this other girl is a fucking whore.
All right? Nah, it's not
worth it. Just fucking, just
get it out of his,
I'm telling you,
if you're any sort of an intelligent
human being, the second year rub one out,
you're going to be thinking,
I don't want to call that other girl.
What am I a fucking idiot?
You're going to look at your kids.
What the hell was I thinking? All
right, other than that, if you don't,
you're an idiot. All right? Because
this is what's going to happen, sir.
You're going to lose your wife.
Your kids are going to hate you.
You're gonna lose your house.
You could end up on a Futon in a studio
apartment and that 25 year old party
girl is going to move on to somebody
else and you're going to be left daily.
Get Dick in your hand.
So both scenarios,
you ended up with your Dick and your hand.
Would you like to do it in a four bedroom
house or a fucking studio apartment
with empty Chinese food containers all
around as you cry yourself to sleep,
wondering what the fuck happened?
Jesus,
I gave him the lumber there. Didn't,
I was a little loose cheeks there.
I gave him the fucking stick between the
balls there. Um, all right, next one.
I am a hideous human being. Dear
bill, I'll be straight to the point.
I am 25 years old and I have been a
closet homosexual for as long as I can
remember. Well Dude, you're gay so you
will gave the second you were born.
That's like me being, I'm, I'm a
straight as long as I can remember.
I guess you've been in the closet
is what you're trying to say.
I don't you confuse me.
Maybe you're right.
Maybe this is another
example of me being dumb.
Maybe I've read the sentence
wrong. Who knows, who cares?
Let's continue sentence number three.
I come from a strict Asian immigrant
family and my parents would commit suicide
if they found out about my orientation.
You know,
I got scared when I saw the first
you basic, you know, orientation.
If you take off the
shun and put the elder,
that was the word that I thought Oriental
was coming on and I was going to get
in trouble here.
Um,
therefore I've been committing petty
crimes for the past few years to get into
jail so I could pursue and
nurture my homosexuality.
You calling bullshit on,
I'll answer this but I'm
calling bullshit on this one.
But there is something for the,
I gotta tell you though,
this is a very unique lie,
so this could actually be true.
You know what?
I'm going to go with this like it's
true just in case it is true and I don't
want to be yet another person turning
my back on this person. All right,
so here we go.
Recently I was locked up after I took
three tabs of acid and I don't really
remember how I got into the
can when I became sober.
During my trip I saw a thousand dog bites.
Oh,
when you were tripping,
you saw a thousand dog bites at me from
every direction and it was the worst
drug experience of my life.
That's why I wasn't surprised
when I woke up in jail anyway,
I was quite relieved to be away from
society until eight hours later I was
released by my parents. The cops called
them while I was tripping in jail.
My question is if it's
better to be in jail,
happy and away from society or an unhappy
and vision individual that satisfies
his parents and social excellence.
Oh, if it's better, dude,
what are you doing? If this is
actually true, come on man, you keep,
you gotta be who you are. All
right? And, uh, I think every day,
I don't know where you live in the
world, but every single day, uh, I,
I just feel like it's that scales are
tipping in the more enlightened favorable
direction and you know what?
You can become a part of
that tipping of the scale.
Um, seeing that, that, that
kid who's going into the NFL,
when he talked about my,
I read that story how when he finally
came out to his teammates and he felt like
a cinder block came off as just,
I know the feeling of having
to carry something around.
I don't know where to tell
that fucking level. So
yeah,
I don't think you're going to regret it.
All right.
Your parents aren't going to fucking kill
themselves. It might take them a while
okay.
To come around. All
right. But if they don't,
you know what? Fuck them. Okay.
Yeah,
I think they will because at the end of
the day, you're their kid. All right,
but what the fuck do I know? But at
the end of the day, they're there.
Every kid at the end of the day has to
make a break with their parents on some
level where your philosophies
do not line up with theirs.
And if you're truly going to pursue
what's gonna make you happy in life,
there has to be the cutting,
you know,
the metaphorical cutting of the
umbilical cord. And you have to be like,
you know what? Fuck them. I
know when I was a little kid,
to me they were gods and I wanted their
approval. And at the end of the day,
I now realize that they're human
beings and they have their flaws.
And what they want me to do does
not fit in with what I want to do.
And if you're not hurting
anybody, which you're not, dude,
w what do you think? You could dig it.
You gotta go to jail and find love.
I mean that it's not a GE. Not exactly
going with some healthy fucking people.
That's like,
that would be like if a woman wanted to
find a good boyfriend and she fucking
went to a place where raw guys
were locked up for abuse and women.
You know what I mean?
Those are some, uh, yeah,
you can find a better boyfriend than
that. Just go to a gay bar, I would say.
You know, or whatever. I don't pretend
to know what the fuck you, that's bad.
That's me saying to a woman, hey, you
want to be the good guy? Go to a bar.
Whatever.
We've reached the end of my intelligence
on this topic we probably did about
five minutes ago, but I'm too dumb to
realize it. But Dude, if this is real,
I'm treating it real. Hello.
It's so fucking crazy. I
don't, I don't, I don't know.
Don't do that. All right. If this is
actually true, I'm choosing to believe it.
Don't fucking do that.
All right, beloved. God,
just sit up doubt.
I don't know how you would do it.
I, you just got to sit
him down. Just say it.
Just get it out there and then you set it
and that it's out there. Yeah. You know,
I don't know what to do after that.
You know what?
Why don't you go meet a gay guy? I'm
sure he can fucking give you some advice.
Why you asking me?
Why am I yelling at you?
I got frustrated because
I don't have the answers.
I feel bad for you if it's true.
All right. I hope it works out.
Don't fucking go to jail.
All right, big gaze. Great.
You fucking in great shape.
You've got all this disposable income
and wherever you're living you're,
you're making the fucking
property value go up.
Okay.
It's a lot of advantages,
you know?
Anyways, let's plow ahead.
Where are we? 54 minutes. Okay.
X Won't sell house.
Dear Bill,
big fan met you in Jacksonville a while
back. I have a quick question for you.
My ex fiance and I were together
for four and a half years.
Why the fuck did you buy a house
with somebody you're not married to?
All right. Now that that doesn't
help you. But if anybody listening,
do not buy a house, do that. Live with
somebody you're not going to marry.
Do not buy a house with somebody you're
not going to if you're not married.
Don't do that shit. Anyways.
During the relationship she read,
she remained loyal while I was deployed
to the Middle East and upon my return I
used my saved up money to buy a
house with her near the beach.
Oh my God.
If this fucking woman,
this is going to somehow make a claim
to your house that you bought with your
serving for our country,
putting your life on the line money.
This would be a new level of whoredom.
Is that a new word?
I think a hoard them.
All right.
Am I not even really,
I know it's a new word,
but that night and I'd be the
proper use of of it already,
which would be very apropos for the
type of fucking moron I am. Alright.
Hang on a second.
Where the hell I am is okay.
It was her dream house and I felt
that if the deployment didn't ruin us,
that nothing would, well, I was wrong.
We decided to split and I tried to be
Amy a couple. Did I say that right?
And let her keep the house.
If she could pay me the closing costs of
about eight grand. This is what guys do.
They just want to cut bait and
fucking leave. Women got that fucking,
they burrow in. She agreed. All right.
Why did you do that? She agreed and
I move. You bought the fucking house.
Did she kick in for it? Maybe I'm
being too hard on her. I Dunno.
She agreed and I moved back home
to New Jersey to start a new life.
It's been nearly a year and she's has
stalled every effort to get this resolved.
When a contract was finally in place,
she decided it needed some
amendments to protect herself.
That basically left me with less money
than we agreed and getting her a house
worth 150 grand for 8,000 bucks.
Dude,
I swear to fucking God if I read
one more of these fucking stories.
All right, and if you're some
fucking woman, all right, and you,
you host one of these shows where you
always talking about the shit that men do.
How about your balance it out?
The way I balanced it out saying
that Lou cheats did a piece of shit.
Fucking move. Why don't you bring
this shit up? This is ridiculous.
He goes,
I throw out the contract and contract,
contacted a realtor to list the house.
They go,
she's refused to sell and her name is on
the title because I'm a fucking idiot.
Long story short,
after I threatened a lawsuit,
a mysterious man who called
himself a family friend,
emailed me and asked to
act as the facilitator for
the deal between the two of
us. My ex do. Don't give into that.
My access not been involved since,
and this guy is a real cunt who
was only out for her. My cousin,
who was a lawyer is guiding
me through the process,
but I need some advice from you
on how to resolve this issue.
I just found out that the family
friend is my new ex's new boyfriend.
I could've told you that.
My question is how do I let them know
that I know I'm like a serial killer who
needs to be caught? What?
I'm like a serial killer.
Who needs to be caught?
Her man caught here, man.
What typo there? I can't
resist them thinking. I don't,
I guess no anymore.
I thought a nice joke barred her
having herpes would be a good start.
I joked that she was too
selfish to even give me that.
Any feedback or advice on the podcast
would really be appreciated. Um,
I usually say cut bait,
but fuck that. Fuck that.
Fuck that.
Uh,
you have two options here and I don't
want to tell you what the second one is.
Uh, the first one is, well,
you have three fight this,
which I would walk away from it,
which I wouldn't.
And number three
would involve a convenient accident
that happened to the house,
but even then, then she probably
fight you for the, uh, uh,
they'd figured out you started
the fire. Don't, don't,
I shouldn't even brought that up.
Listen, this is what you gotta do.
You just got to accept the fact
that you were in for a long fight here
and that lawyers are going to get most of
the money,
but that bitch is not going to get
the house now to go that route.
Oh God,
I don't want to tell you to quit,
but my world, I would just be like, look,
you want 150,000 fucking dollar house,
just take the fucking
house free and clear.
MMM.
It costs you 150 grand to get rid of
this fucking devil woman that's going to
take that new guide down.
She's going to take that guy down.
Yeah,
it, I mean, granted, I only heard
your side of the story. All right.
And I'm taking this as the truth
and if this is the truth that,
that that's not the,
that's not you.
You don't want that devil
woman in your fucking life.
That is some evil fucking shit.
MMM.
Ah, okay. I got to walk away
from this story because it's,
it's actually making me fucking mad and
I don't have a dog in the fight here.
What I'm doing is I am
inserting myself into the story,
who I would be in this fucking story of,
uh,
Jesus do. You're young, you're young.
Get into the best shape of your life.
Hit on women out of your fucking league
and then treat her like a fucking Queen
Mary her and then walked by this
bitch someday on the street.
That's what I would do. All
right. Oh, you fucking cunt.
How long to wait for sex?
Short and simple.
Yeah.
Adolf Hitler.
I don't know what that means.
I'm 26 and I started dating a girl,
a lady.
We got to talking about
doing the dirty now Jesus.
And she'd said she doesn't
want to be sexual for a while
probably. Cause you say,
Hey Lee Lee, say we do
the dirty air. Me Man,
I got my fork and balled over here,
whether it's debt that dads do
it and I liked to a plat he sees,
uh,
per se a man was l a my question is,
how long is too long to wait?
I don't want to pressure her.
I want her to feel comfortable. But at
the same time of 26 what do you think?
Also, side note, what do
you think about the cheese?
Okay,
a cup. I already went
on that. Um, all right.
Uh,
I don't want to pressure her dude.
You don't give a fuck about this woman.
Get out of the relationship.
You just want a banger.
You want to fucker 26 so it got my
fucking balls. If full over here,
what am I supposed to do? Oh, by the way,
what'd you think about that thing
that guy did in the hockey game?
I'm supposed to give a fuck.
You couldn't even get through this God
damn question. Dumb fucking sidetrack.
This is what I do. I do
break up with her. All right?
She doesn't want to have sex with you.
No means no. Don't pressure Jesus Christ.
Do you want to have sex with her while
she's sobbing? You fucking Weirdo. Look,
you don't give a shit so
goddamn phone buzzing there.
You don't give a fuck about this woman.
Okay. You don't break up with her. Okay.
And go find some woman that's
going to jump on your Dick.
Cause that's what you want right now and
your life because you're 26. All right.
There you go. He says thank you. Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself. Same to you sir.
Same deal.
Jay's is that phone never stopped ringing.
Okay.
Why won't it stop ringing? It's
actually my wife's phone. Hey Nia,
your phone is buzzing and
it's not going to stop.
Okay.
It's just like the Illuminati calling
for the, they fucking go around you.
What is it doing? It's
buzzing. Oh, it's your alarm.
Oh, all right. How are you
doing? I already pushed.
Huh? Um, I'm actually wrapping
up the podcast right now.
All right, there you go. That's the
kind of interaction you live for.
You don't want that. You have to, while
you get to know the person you live with.
That means I'm watching something
interesting you do? Um, all right,
well let's a podcast for this week.
Everybody, uh, it hope you enjoyed it.
I hope I made you lab. Look at any player
in the fuck a week. Um, I am going to be,
why don't we look it up here?
Why don't we look this shit up here?
See what the fuck I'm going to be.
Where am I going to be?
Oh,
Billy freckles built bar.com.
Oh, by the way, everybody, uh,
if you,
if you're going to think of,
if you thinking about buying something
on amazon.com and you would also like to
donate to this podcast,
go to the podcast page on [inaudible] dot
com and click on the Amazon Dot Amazon
banner, right? It'll take you right to
Amazon. Doesn't cost you any extra money.
They kicked me a little, a doe ray
me there for Russian. You there?
If you don't want to do what I understand,
you know your fingers got better things
to do, then do it. The extra two clicks.
All right, let's get on with the shows
here. William, a William Burrow here.
It's going to be at the Flynn Theater and
Oh, I'm not Montpelier and Burlington,
Vermont,
Burlington coat factory.
Come on down and get yourself
a windbreaker. Going to
be at the Burlington, uh,
low the Flint theater in Burlington,
Vermont on April 25th.
April 26 I'm going to be at the,
uh, state theater in Portland,
Maine for two shows. They
added a late show, I guess.
And then on April 27th,
I'm going to be at the palace
theater in Albany, New York.
There you go. So please come out to the
show. That's the end of the podcast.
I'll Cleo, get up your
body. Come on up here.
Come on. Jesus Christ. Now you won't
get up on the bed. Come here. Come on.
Come on. There you go. What's up buddy?
Fucking pay. Make me want to work on. All
right, that's a podcast for this week.
Go fuck yourselves or have
something else in French.
I'll talk to you next week.
Go fuck yourselves.